[Musik]
ihnen allen frohe Weihnachten und
schönen guten Abend in aller Kürze und
vielleicht noch vor ihrem
Weihnachtsessen bringen wir Sie auf den
Stand der Dinge und beginnen mit der
traditionellen Weihnachtsbotschaft des
Papstes vor 70.000 Gläubigen und
Touristen auf dem Petersplatz Beklagte
Papst franziskus den eisigen Wind des
Krieges er rief dazu auf an die
Millionen Ukraine zu denken die ohne
Strom und Heizung sind oder vertrieben
wurden aus Rom Annette hilsenbeck
es ist ein Weihnachtsfest geprägt vom
Krieg in der Ukraine und Papst
franziskus spricht vor Zehntausenden
Gläubigen auf dem Petersplatz in Rom vom
Leid und der Zerstörung die zehn Monate
Krieg verursacht haben ruft zum Frieden
auf
unser Blick mögt die Gesichter unserer
ukrainischen Brüder und Schwestern
aufnehmen die diese Weihnachten im
Dunkeln in der Kälte oder weit weg von
ihrem Zuhause erleben
der Herr erleuchte den Verstand derer
die die Macht haben die Waffen zum
Schweigen zu bringen und diesem
sinnlosen Krieg ein sofortiges Ende zu
setzen
auch an Konflikte etwa in Syrien oder
dem Jemen die in den Hintergrund geraten
sind erinnert der Papst den Gläubigen
Spende der den Segen urbiert orbi für
die Stadt und den Erdkreis der besagt
dass alle Sünden vergeben werden
die Geburt Jesu als Botschafter des
Friedens eine päpstliche
Weihnachtsbotschaft die den Gläubigen
Hoffnung geben soll
Hoffnung für viele Millionen Ukraine das
Letzte woran sie sich nach über 10
Monaten Krieg Klammern können in Kiew
feierten sie heute so wie wir den ersten
Weihnachtstag absolut unüblich orthodoxe
Ukraine sowie Russen feiern Weihnachten
normalerweise Anfang Januar über diese
Premiere und was dahinter steckt eine
Brühl
[Musik]
Frieda sei mit euch singt der Priester
in der Verklärung Christi Kirche in Kiew
es ist das erste Mal dass sie auch hier
schon im Dezember Weihnachten feiern und
wie alles hat auch das mit dem Krieg zu
tun
im Kalender das bedeutet sich von
Russland zu distanzieren und enger an
Europa und die westliche Welt
heranzurücken
die orthodoxen Kirchen in Russland und
der Ukraine gehen schon seit 2019
getrennte Wege der Krieg sorgt jetzt für
den endgültigen Bruch Kutsche muss wir
wollen mit der ganzen zivilisierten Welt
feiern nicht mit Russland das uns
angegriffen hat und unsere Kinder unsere
Leute unsere Soldaten Söhne und Brüder
tötet
mitten im Gottesdienst Luftalarm es gibt
Unruhe alle schauen auf ihre Handys mit
der Alarm App
[Musik]
in der Kirche und dem ganzen Land ist
Alarm das macht mir große Sorgen
wir fragen Sie nach Ihrem
Weihnachtswunsch
Frieden nur Frieden sagt sie
und dann gehen während der Kommunion die
Lichter aus Stromausfall es ist
kriegsweihnacht in Kiew
und es sind genau diese
Herausforderungen des ukrainekrieges die
Bundespräsident Steinmeier auch ins
Zentrum seiner Weihnachtsansprache
rückte seine Zwischenbilanz positiv
Deutschland sei nicht in Panik verfallen
und die Menschen hätten sich nicht
auseinandertreiben lassen Patricia
Wiedemeier
es sind zwei Themen die dieses Jahr
geprägt haben zwei Themen um die es in
der Weihnachtsansprache geht der Krieg
in der Ukraine und der Klimawandel
Steinmeier dankt den deutschen für ihr
Verständnis für ihre Offenheit gegenüber
Fremden gegenüber Flüchtlingen ich weiß
wie viel diese Krise ihnen allen
abverlangt dass viele sich einschränken
müssen
aber unsere Großherzigkeit im Umgang
miteinander
die kann uns niemand nehmen bei allen
schlechten Nachrichten müsste man auch
auf das schauen was Zuversicht gebe
die Ukraine behauptet sich mit großem
Mut Europa steht zusammen und unser Land
wächst in der Herausforderung wieder
einmal über sich hinaus diese Zuversicht
müsste man mitnehmen ins neue Jahr so
der Appell des Bundespräsidenten und
auch beim Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
sei jeder Bürger gefordert egal ob jung
oder alt ich wünsche mir dass die
älteren auch spät im Leben noch einmal
bereit sind sich zu verändern und dass
die Jüngeren sich engagieren dass sie
kritisch sind ohne der Sache des
Klimaschutzes zu schaden indem sie
andere gegen sich aufbringen alles
Stärken was uns verbindet kämpfen für
einen Frieden der noch nicht greifbar
sei das ist die Botschaft der
diesjährigen Weihnachtsansprache
die gesamte Weihnachtsansprache von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier die können
Sie direkt nach unserer heute Sendung
sehen
wegen des arbeitsverbots für ihre
MitarbeiterInnen in Afghanistan stellen
drei internationale Hilfsorganisationen
ihre Tätigkeit vorerst ein das haben
Save the Children care und der
norwegische Flüchtlingsrat mitgeteilt
Außenministerin baerbock nannte es
inakzeptabel dass die Taliban humanitäre
Hilfe zum Spielball ihrer
Frauenverachtung machten gestern hatte
die afghanische Regierung Frauen die
Arbeit bei
Nichtregierungsorganisationen verboten
in China wütet die schwerste coronawelle
seit Beginn der Pandemie jetzt will das
Land laut Gesundheitskommission keine
täglichen infektions- und Todeszahlen
mehr veröffentlichen in den vergangenen
Tagen gab es immer wieder Kritik an den
wohl viel zu niedrigen Meldungen im
ganzen Land sind Krankenhäuser überfüllt
täglich sollen sich Millionen Menschen
mit Corona infizieren
bei einem Lawinenabgang in Österreich
sind nach ersten Erkenntnissen etwa 10
Menschen verschüttet worden das Unglück
ereignete sich nach Polizeiangaben im
Skigebiet Lech Zürs im Vorarlberg ein
verschütteter konnte nach kurzer Zeit
gerettet werden nach den übrigen wird
mit lawinensuchhunden gesucht
klirrende Kälte und extremer Schneefall
Wintersturm Elliot hält Teile der USA
weiter in Atem mehr als 20 Menschen
kamen bislang ums Leben berichten
US-Medien besonders betroffen der
Bundesstaat New York an der Grenze zu
Kanada hier sind die Notdienste teils
zusammengebrochen 10.000 Haushalte sind
ohne Strom Heizungen funktionieren nicht
mehr
dann schauen wir mal was das Wetter hier
bei uns macht morgen Vormittag Regen von
der Nordsee bis zur Donau am Nachmittag
muss dann überall mit Regen gerechnet
werden dazu im Nordwesten am Nachmittag
stürmischer Wind und kurze Gewitter die
Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 13 Grad
um kurz nach 23 Uhr meldet sich Moritz
Neuss mit den neuesten Nachrichten in
heute Express so viel von uns für Sie
und Ihre Liebsten noch einen schönen und
entspannten Weihnachtsabend und bis
morgen
[Musik]